LOOKING TO TIE OR GET THE THREE,
AND CURRY FOR THE LEAD.
RATTLED IT OUT.
RUDY IS GOING TO TRACK IT DOWN.
STEPH ONE MORE TIME FOR THE
ADVANTAGE -- GOOD!
IF AT FIRST YOU DON'T SUCCEED,
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SAY.
TRY, TRY AGAIN.
ESPECIALLY IF YOUR NAME IS
STEPHEN CURRY.
>> Kalenna: WHAT A BIG SHOT.
AND LOONEY GAVE STEPH A SECOND
OPPORTUNITY.
AND HE CASHES IN THE THREE.
AND A ONE-POINT LEAD WITH 13
SECOND LEFT.
HE IS SO BIG TIME, AND HE NEVER
LOSES CONFIDENCE, AND YOU LOSE
THE FIRST ONE, AND THE MOVEMENT
WITHOUT THE BALL, AND THE JUKE
MOVE WITHOUT THE BALL GOT HIM
THE ADVANTAGE AGAINST O'NEALE,
AND AGAIN USING GOBERT, AND WHO
IS GUARDING DRAYMOND?
NOBODY.
SO MUCH SPACE, AND LOOK AT WHERE
GOBERT S AND HE IS SUPPOSED TO
BE GUARDING GOBERT.
AND NOW, LOOKING AT THE BIG
OFFENSIVE REBOUND WITH 13 BOARDS
TONIGHT, AND THAT IS GOING TO
GIVE STEPH THE